non vedo l'ora che sia natale non vedo
l'ora di riunirmi alla mia famiglia e
abbracciare tutti
chi vorresti abbracciare scusa a quanto
pare non lo sai ma c'è una pandemia in
corsa non puoi abbracciare proprio
nation tesoro questo sarà un natale un
po particolare si sa e dovrei fare un po
più di attenzione e soprattutto coi
nonni ma questo non significa che non
potrai circondarti dell'amore e
dell'affetto dei tuoi cari
per me il natale un momento magico mi
ricorda la mia infanzia felice passate
in famiglia tra coccole giochi
spensieratezza tra coccole giochi
spensieratezza a chi si fosse
dimenticata che non ti sopportava
nessuno neanche tua madre
come faccio io la sopportano un diavolo
che urlava e faceva i capricci da
mattina alla sera per non parlare di
quando ci arrivi sotto al tavolo
iniziati più concertino obbligando tutti
ad ascoltarti le canzoni di natale a
bastonate della storia così diceva zia
lui 6 pareti quando uscì a giocare in
guardian sono tutte baggianate
i bambini sono toni di dio e nessuno si
permetterebbe mai di insultarli
piuttosto cantami una bella canzone di
natale che sono circa due minuti e 23
secondi che non ne ascolto una
basta basta io odio le canzoni di natale
sono sempre le stesse cifre versano le
palle tutti gli anni con le stesse
canzoni e si stupiscono giochiamo il
natale
io amo il natale per chi a natale siamo
tutti più buoni questa è la mia bambina
felice e gioiosa sta per vomitare siete
solo dei poveri ipocriti risultate tutto
l'anno e magicamente a natale vi volete
tutti bene falsi ipocriti
chissà che regali mi porteranno natale
tanti tantissimi regali tesoro mio chi
ha il cuore buono si merita tanti regali
capite cosa intendo tutti i giovani
gioia mora e famiglie e poi l'unica cosa
che mi interessa sono sciolte iarley
siete dei poveri materialisti travestiti
da santi chissà quante cose buone
cucinerà mamma non vedo l'ora buffon se
non vedo l'ora di abu farmi fate tutti
così vi mangiate pure le sedie e poi dal
26 in porto e che a lamentarvi che c'è
chi conosce brava tesoro devi crescere e
giusto che mangi e ti libro proprio
bisogno di staccare la spina dallo
studio e godermi queste vacanze
senti un po ti ricordi cosa arriva dopo
non e capodanno
la mia amica befana ma dopo il natale
arriva la cessione
ma sei bravissima tranquilla li passerai
tutti quanti e dove la trovi la
concentrazione sul tuo ragazzo vive
all'estero non vive rete da cinque
lunghezze mm quanto mi manca
in effetti che natale è se lui non è qui
con me lui è con te nel tuo cuore è
questo quello che conta è il tuo cuore
ma certo che cosa è morto
io invece penso che tu abbia più forma
delle renne del qui presente adesso
basta non rovinerà il natale a questa
ragazza ma si tanto se non hai vicino
tutte le persone che ami è un giorno
come un altro contento
guarda che cosa hai appena fatto lei è
spento lo spirito natalizio e hai fatto
rattristi re non è che se tu odi il
natale devi per forza far odiare agli
altri ma io non ho spento lo spirito
natalizio propria nessuno lo show l'ho
fatta a ragionare e visto che una
ragazza intelligente ha capito che tutta
questa frenesia terra è solo un modo per
colmare le proprie debolezze per non
affrontare la dura realtà
e tu da che parte stai fa meno sapere
qui sotto nei commenti
[Musica]